Gentlemen, congratulations.
It's down to the two
of you to decide who's
going to leave here with the
title of "Forged in Fire"
champion and that
check for $10,000.
Now, in this final round,
we're sending you back
to your home forges
for four days
to build an iconic
weapon from history.
We want you to build this.
[suspenseful music]
Oh.
This is the
elephant tusk sword.
NARRATOR: Dating as far
back as the 6th century BC,
the mighty elephant was
used during warfare,
often armed with the
fierce elephant tusk sword.
This lethal weapon featured a
socket that connected directly
to the elephant's tusk.
The double-edged
blade was designed
to inflict massive
destruction as an elephant
charged through barricades
and ranks of enemy soldiers.
Throughout history,
there's evidence
of thousands of elephant tusk
swords being used in battle.
However, only four pairs of
these intimidating weapons
still exist today.
I've never seen
anything like it.
I'm trying to figure out how I'm
even going to construct this.
A terrifying feeling is
starting to set in again.
Good luck.
We'll see you in four days.
Hell, yeah.
My name is Matt [inaudible].
I'm 38 years old from
Knoxville, Tennessee.
I'm a senior engineer and
a part-time bladesmith.
I'm not normally
a competitive guy.
But for this, I
made an exception.
Because I'm here to win.
My adrenaline's already
pumping through my veins.
And I'm ready for
that challenge.
I've got my width
that I'm looking for.
But my workpiece might
be a little too thin.
I'm going to try and forge weld
in a mild steel medial ridge.
So I'm going to
get some mild steel
and try and forge weld
that onto both sides.
All right.
Now, we're cooking.
This sword is meant
for an elephant.
So the amount of force that's
going to go into the blade
is going to be off the charts.
We want as even of a
heat as we can get.
Check it with a magnet.
Make sure that we're
at a critical temp,
and then pull it out,
drop it in my quench oil.
Good so far.
[suspenseful music]
I don't see any cracks.
All the welds held up,
nothing blew apart.
So far, so good.
Now, just to make
it look pretty.
I'm going to start
off by securing
the blade to the socket.
I'm worried about possibly
overheating the blade.
So I'm going to have
to take some extra care
to make sure the heat
doesn't travel and ruin
the temper on the blade.
Let that cool off.
Doing a kind of test
fit of the sword.
Perfect.
Everything goes
together smooth as silk.
This blade is crazy.
I never would have
imagined myself
making something like this.
So I'm kind of excited to
see what kind of destruction
it does or maybe the
sword blows apart.
I don't know.
Looks pretty sweet.
My name's Jayden [inaudible].
I'm 19 years old.
And I started bladesmithing
at about age 15.
My entire life, I've gotten
in trouble for two things--
playing with knives
and playing with fire.
And so eventually,
it clicked in my mind
that I could make
knives with fire.
And it really just
went from there.
Everything's looking good.
I think that it's
all welded up well.
I'm going to start
preparing to weld
the socket cap onto the blade.
If I do these welds incorrectly,
I will end up with cracks.
I could end up with
the whole blade,
basically, just breaking off.
[rock music]
The welds ended up great.
So I'm feeling good
about where I am.
And today's mostly just going to
be making this thing beautiful.
So I think I'm going to
grind it like I would an ax.
I'm going to do
big convex edges.
Because all of that extra meat
in there will help support
the cutting edge itself.
That's exactly how I wanted it.
It's way cooler than I ever
thought it would have been.
And I'm happy with it.
At this point, I could show up.
And on the first hit,
it could snap in half
and I'd walk away happy.
I hope it doesn't, though.
I do want to win.
[laughs]
Bladesmiths, welcome
to the kill test.
In battle, these swords were
attached to elephants who just
rammed across its opponents.
Find out what kind of lethal
damage your weapon will do.
We're going to go hog-wild
on this ballistics dummy.
Jayden, you're up first.
You ready for this?
- Hell, yeah.
Let's do this.
Ooh.
Oh.
Ah.
I wasn't expecting
his head to come off.
All right.
Jayden, let's talk
about your weapon here.
Every thrust was deadly.
It went all the way through.
What I do like is I can see the
Damascus pattern on your blade
there.
Jayden, your elephant
tusk sword, it will kill.
That's all I wanted.
All right.
Matt, your turn.
So are you ready?
Hopefully, my sword is not
"irrelephant" after this test.
[laughter]
We're going to have fun.
[suspenseful music]
MATT: Ooh.
All right, Matt, it
penetrates very deep.
And on the way out, it cuts.
It's a weighted
weapon right here
that when it
thrust-- see the hole
right in the middle of
the ballistics dummy--
it destroyed
everything in there.
Your weapon right
here, it will kill.
Thank you, Doug.
All right, gentlemen,
the strength test--
we've mounted your elephant
tusk swords on our battering ram
here.
And I will be attacking
that armored soldier.
All right.
Jayden, you ready for this?
Yeah, let's do it.
DAVID BAKER: OK.
[clank]
Ooh.
That's terrifying.
Jayden, I really
have to commend you
on the artistry of this blade.
The low-layer
pattern really pops.
The connections here are
all really beautifully done.
And for this test, that
tip still has an edge.
Everything is right
and tight and true,
and nothing's changed.
Well done.
Thank you.
- Matt, you ready to roll?
- Absolutely.
OK.
[suspenseful music]
[clank]
So, Matt, your
blade held up fine.
The tip, it's a
little bit duller
than when it started out with.
But I wouldn't run my finger
down this edge, so nicely done.
It held up beautifully.
Thank you.
All right, bladesmiths, we
know your weapons can kill.
And we know they are strong.
Now, it's time to find out
how sharp your weapons are.
This is the sharpness test,
the guillotine fruit slice.
We're going to take your
elephant tusk sword,
release it, and try to
cut through the fruit.
I want to see clean cuts
all the way through.
Jayden, you're up first.
You ready?
- Hell, yeah.
- All right.
Let's do this.
JAYDEN: Nice.
All right, Jayden,
your edge here cut
all the way through cleanly.
Bottom line, sir, your elephant
tusk sword, it will cut.
All right, Matt, your turn, sir.
You ready?
I'm ready.
[rock music]
MATT: [exhales]
All right, Matt, let's
talk about your weapon here.
The weight on this, it drives
the cut all the way through.
Your edge is sharp.
More importantly,
sir, it will cut.
Thank you, Doug.
Well, Jayden
and Matt, you guys
both performed exceptionally
well during your tests.
But as you know,
only one of you guys
will be leaving here with
the title of "Forged in Fire"
champion.
And today's "Forged in
Fire" champion is Jayden.
Congratulations, you won, man.
Matt, unfortunately,
that means you
did not come out on top today.
I'm going to have to ask
you to please step out.
I'm proud of the
sword that I turned in.
They were virtually
the same performance.
Good job, man.
Yeah, you too.
And Jayden's weapon, he
turned in a work of art.
And I think he
deserves the title.
First thing I'm going to do
when I get home, kiss my wife
and crack open a beer.
Well, Jayden, that means you
are today's "Forged in Fire"
champion.
You're going to be leaving here
with a check for $10,000, man.
Congratulations.
Thank you.
[applause]
I'm the newest "Forged
in Fire" champion.
And I'm really stoked about it.
How old are you again?
19.
19 years old--
that is extremely
impressive, man.
Thank you.
Whoo!
I'm so bad at emotion.
[laughs]
[music playing]